origine nature fait pousser du cannabis
depuis trois ans à
Sainte-Agathe-des-Monts l'entreprise ne
comptait que quelques employés au départ
ils sont aujourd'hui 80 la clé du succès
selon le PDG gardez les deux pieds sur
terre dans une industrie ou certains ont
la tête dans les nuages on regarde pas
un croissance extrême j'ai toujours dit
j'ai aucune vouloir d'être le plus grand
le plus reconnu à travers le monde
contrairement à plusieurs autres
producteurs origines nature est en bonne
santé financière l'entreprise est
rentable depuis sa première livraison et
la plus financer une expansion presque
entièrement avec ses profits 7 millions
de dollars de agrandissement 2 millions
ont été fondés avec un prêt 5 millions
c'était les bénéfices de l'entreprise
qui ont été réinvestis le producteur de
cannabis détenu par une quarantaine
d'investisseurs privés ne sait pas
lancer en bourse comme les grands
joueurs qui voulaient amasser des
capitaux rapidement pour dominer le
marché il regardait l'industrie
seulement d'un côté finance puis pour
les autres c'était juste le green Gold
Rush qui s'en vient on va lancer
là-dedans puis on va faire plein
d'argent la Gold Rush qu'on attendait
n'a pas nécessairement arriver depuis la
légalisation en octobre 2018 les ventes
de cannabis sont en constante
augmentation de 2019 à 2022 ils ont plus
que tripler pour atteindre plus de 4
milliards et demi de dollars au pays
mais l'industrie s’attendait à plus on
se retrouve aujourd'hui dans un contexte
de surproduction les entrepôts débordent
du côté du cannabis séché on est à peu
près à 3 pour 1 3 fois les ventes en
inventaire par contre pour certaines
catégories de produits comme par exemple
les semences on est à 30 pour un du côté
des produits consommables et de base on
serait de l'ordre à peu près 10 pour un
tous les capacités de production de
l'industrie augmenter beaucoup plus
rapidement que la l'augmentation de la
demande durable ce qui fait en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui on se ramasse avec un
déséquilibre entre l'offre et la demande
qui fait en sorte que les prix ont
tendance à chuter ce qui m'a appelé le
plusieurs acteurs de l'industrie les
grands joueurs qui ont investi des
sommes colossales pour construire des
mégas installations n'arrivent pas à les
rentabiliser on récoltait peut-être 10
000 plantes cannabis par semaine c'est
le cas de canopigraal par exemple qui a
décidé de mettre fin à son partenariat
avec les serres Bertrand Mirabel en 2018
le plus grand producteur de tomate rose
en Amérique du Nord avec converti ses
installations pour cultiver du cannabis
avec l'entreprise ontarienne qui l'a
finalement largué il y a quelques mois
en ce moment Stéphane Bertrand fait
pousser des Haricots je pense que canapé
réaliser que le marché était pas
totalement à l'eau pour une grande ferme
comme ici qu'on pourrait générer je vais
peut-être 50-60 tonnes par année c'était
beaucoup trop pour lui l'aventure a été
rentable beaucoup plus même que de faire
pousser des légumes il aurait aimé
continuer dans le cannabis mais il
n'aurait pas trouvé preneur
avec d'autres producteurs la ferme est
énorme ici est-ce qu'on est capable de
vendre une tonne de cannabis par semaine
la réponse est NON au Québec en tout cas
on a 24 salles de croissance les plus
petits producteurs semblent donc mieux
tirer leur épingle du jeu en ce moment
avec une croissance graduelle rose
science vie est devenu profitable il ne
plus important fournisseur de la société
québécoise du cannabis a beaucoup de
gros joueurs ont voulu conquérir le
Canada ont voulu conquérir le monde du
jour au lendemain quelques mois après la
légalisation notre approche a été
complètement différente on a décidé de
se concentrer sur un marché l'entreprise
dunting est cool la quasi-totalité de
ces récoltes au Québec et l'offre aussi
des services de représentation aux
producteurs canadiens qui veulent
commercialiser leurs produits dans la
province une façon de diversifier ses
revenus une des clés du succès c'est
juste d'avoir des objectifs clairs que
ce soit de se concentrer sur le Québec
ou de se concentrer sur une autre
province
c'est de savoir exactement ce que la
compagnie veut atteindre et c'est
d'avoir un objectif et non pas un
million mais les conditions sont plus
difficiles qu'ailleurs au pays de toutes
les provinces c'est au Québec la
consommation et les ventes de cannabis
par habitant sont les plus faibles
d'agrandir mais avec encore beaucoup
beaucoup de défis et les gros défauts
Québec c'est vraiment les restrictions
qui sont imposées par le gouvernement et
non pas par la sqdc les points de vente
sont moins nombreux l'âge minimal pour
acheter du cannabis c'est plus élevé les
normes entourants les produits
comestibles sont plus strictes et la
liste continue il y a aucun produit de
vapotage qui sont acceptés les produits
de vapotage représentent une grosse
partie des ventes dans le reste du pays
donc c'est une opportunité de croissance
qui n'est pas disponible aux producteurs
qui font affaires avec la sqdc en ce
moment pour les producteurs de cannabis
la route est parsemée d'embûches
certains avaient vu la légalisation
comme la prochaine ruée vers l'or ils
avaient peut-être oublié que bien des
prospecteurs n'ont jamais connu la
richesse